thank you for joining us America open
phones a triple eight eight two five
five two two five I don't always take a
caller through an entire segment but you
know what I was walking through with
Marcel there was something you need to
understand because I think it's it
addresses everyone needs to know that
that you got it you got to read to get
better you got to you got to set a goal
into the distance and break the goal
down into manageable parts that you take
a step through as you climb the ladder
to get to the top of the house is one
step at a time you don't get to skip a
step and you walk through steps to get
to where you're going if you want to
lose weight if you want a great marriage
there are elements to that and you need
to define that what it looks like very
very clearly and then and then read
about and study people and find other
people who are doing better than you at
whatever it is you want to do in his
case we were talking about his income
and see that that is the problem with
the broken argument why I won't engage
the broken argument of we need to
increase the minimum wage because the
minimum wage hasn't got anything to do
with anything
it doesn't less than 1/10 of 1% listen
to that one tenth of one percent of
Americans try to feed their family on
the minimum wage it isn't it applies to
part-time work to teenagers and to a few
other things here and there but
one-tenth that means 99.9 percent of
Americans don't live on the minimum wage
now he wasn't far above that at 1350 was
he 1315 hours that's not that's not
actually robbing the bank right there
dude I mean that's rough it's tough to
pay bills on that money but he was
working forty hours he's raising two
boys by himself that's a good man right
there but the thing I don't want him to
get caught up in is that this even that
this political debate indicates is that
you're stuck there you're
her stock the only place you get stuck
is between your ears you know I was
working for a company one time and they
said we're going to move you to a
different project and let you do a
hundred and fifty percent more work for
70 percent of the money
in other words gave me a promotion that
gave me more work to do for less money
and I was supposed to be thrilled about
that somehow and I was in my 20s and I
said guys I just I'll stay here I would
rather not take that position thank you
for offering it that's not a it's not
palatable to me I don't want to do that
and people say well I company was
screwing you know they made me a bad
offer and then they came back and said
well you know Dave really this is your
only option we're not going to leave you
in this position we need you to take
that other project I said then pay me
well we don't have that budgeted for
that and I said well why would you ask
anyone to take more work for less money
and expect them to be excited about it
well you know this is what corporate
says to do and this is what we're doing
and and so you know now I got an option
at that point I can either take that job
or they're going to fire me you know
what I discovered there was a third
option I could quit because I really
don't want to go do more work for less
money after I've earned my keep and on
top of that I don't want to work with
people that are this stupid if this is
what they're asking me to do in looking
you straight in the face and end it and
so I could sit there and go this company
screwing me they screw me I quit you
know whose fault if they can screw me
you know he's fault they would have been
mine cuz I was dumb enough to stay there
so all these people griping about
Walmart doesn't pay and McDonald's
doesn't pay hey you know if you don't
like to pay here's an idea leave make
like a tree leaf be gone in that
interesting thing you're not stuck baby
it's America you can cut grass walk dogs
you're not stuck you can babysit
babysitters in America babe
be sitting kids teenage girls make 15 to
20 bucks an hour that's if you can get
one and all of it paid parents letters
at a mint 15 20 bucks an hour you make a
lot more than that mowing grass you got
your own lawn mower
I said dirty and sweaty work though I'll
tell you I've done it I got hay fever to
my eyes used to swell shut the dumbest
looking thing but you know what you're
not stuck you are not stuck that's the
message of Marcel's call you can read a
book take a class move on to the next
thing you are not a victim and your life
is not a snapshot it is a film strip it
is continuously moving so get in the
flow baby get in the zone there is stuff
you can do and you know the problem is
we keep telling people they can't and
you know what someone believe you
you keep telling people they can't long
enough you know what they like they
can't executor used to say my buddy used
to say said if you think you can or you
think you can't you're right you tell
people long enough you can't make it the
economy is fixed the structural flaws of
the economy that's a favorite liberal
phrase right there I like that phrase
the structural flaws of the economy
translation the little man can't get
ahead we're stuck we need communism the
structural flaws of the economy you
don't have control of a ratio Alger is
dead you don't have control of your
future well you got to take you're gonna
have trouble convincing me of that can
see I started with nothing became a
millionaire by the time I was 26 I was
so stupid I lost it all and I started
again and now I'm a multi-millionaire
and I'm so dumb I had to do it twice I'm
the little man that got a head twice and
I'm not genius and I'm not pretty enough
for television that's why I'm on radio
god help you people that watch me online
we're sorry it's like watching ugly
paint dry we know but you're stuck with
it and you know it just it is what it is
y'all yeah
hard work tell the truth
and somebody needs some help and help
them you're not stuck you're not a
victim you can read books find someone
to mentor and disciple you you can set
some goals take the incremental steps to
get there and in 10 years double triple
or quadruple your income and do it in a
field that you love you are not stuck
and don't you let liberals tell you
you're stuck you're not stuck this is
the greatest country the world has ever
known this is the greatest country the
world has ever known
never in the history of man has an
economy been so vibrant with so many
opportunities for anyone in any station
of life any color sex creed national
origin could get ahead faster than they
can right now today in the United States
of America and yet we have people
running around all over the place
badmouth etre stop it every time you
badmouth her you tell a young person
they can't succeed
don't tell young people they can't
succeed we need them to succeed we need
the inventions that are in their souls
and in their brains some of them are
walking around with how to cure cancer
in their head don't tell them they can't
succeed some of them are walking around
you know how to solve the whole they'll
solve the entire energy problem and it's
in two or three of his head if you don't
tell them they can't succeed and so they
live in their mother's basement playing
Nintendo instead of going and succeeding
tell them they can win
tell them they can win and believe they
can win when you're telling them that
see that's what Marcel's call was about
Marcel is a 24 year old guy wife left
him with two little kids he's making
$13.50 an hour but that's not Marcel's
destiny it's not his destiny he made a
phone call to a weird radio station
weird radio show I just sent that guy
like 25 books just now he reads every
one of those books I'll guarantee you if
he reads every one of those books within
a year his income will double I'll
guarantee you all you want bet I'm right
he's not stuck until he decides he's
stuck or until you telling me stuck long
enough that he believes he's stuck he's
not stuck he's got a future and don't
you steal it from him either
you tell him he can win you know why cuz
he can really win this is the Dave
Ramsey show
you